all right guys strap in because this is
a big one we've done teams we've done
plays we've done casters and just about
everything else in between but we've
never done a top 10 list about the best
players across all of esports now our
criteria for this is pretty varied we're
talking about individual skill we're
talking about trophy cases we're talking
about influence on the scene but more
than that guys we're talking about the
players who have thrilled us with their
skill who have captured our hearts with
their passion whose names live on long
after their games are gone this is the
top 10 legendary players in all of
esports
starting us off is the player who has
redefined what it means to be the best
player in counter-strike
simple
nitro does have a model of another smoke
so it could be really rough for simple
to actually get through this he's gonna
throw the awp oh my god
he's been in two major grand finals has
become a household name for cs fans all
over the world and is arguably the
greatest mechanical player in cs history
smokes
double smokes in the same place they're
simple just jumping casually into the
side he's gonna fall down and get right
there all right
from simple are you serious what is that
you can't do that simple that's not
allowed this is not fpl this is a major
although he still doesn't have that
major title he's been looking for
simple is still young there's a lot of
career left for csgo's young goat 14
seconds they've got to get out simple
gets only one in return jumps up and
somehow finds sergey but he hasn't found
the bomb he will now and he goes away
from default because he doesn't want to
get naked he also knows there's a flank
and he also knows he needs positions he
actually gets the first one he's got a
chance he knows aloo's up close and he's
not around oh that's what we like from
simple
coming into the number nine spot is the
greatest league of legends player china
has ever produced uzi
[Music]
and the choo choo trains in the back
lines everyone's slow
everyone from ig is just gonna get taken
down triple kill being picked up by uzi
chasing down the fourth quarter duke's
the only one left alone
uzi is considered the greatest 80 carry
of all time with mechanical excellence
almost no one can match millions are
still pushing into their base that's a
root that's a dead blippo he gets turned
into zombie scion mode and fanatical
running for their lives keep your eyes
on reckless he's caught he's silenced
he's feasted but he's not dead yet
finally xiaohu takes him down royal
never give up the quadra kill for
housing and fanatic armed dumpsters
outside of the game uzi has become
immensely popular in china landing
sponsorship deals with nike and breaking
down barriers for esports in his home
country and although he might not be on
top right now
he's not going anywhere uzi is coming in
from the back side surprise here comes
the vade kill for white sun's not going
to escape this one they focused on uzi
but look at him he's still alive he's
still surviving he stays
taking our number eight spot is the most
consistent player in cs go history it's
a crossfire it's a blunder both go
tonight gold's gonna win it off and then
there is a knife because device comes
back around oh my god device with two in
one round that's insane device has the
most hltv mvps of any player in the game
along with the rest of astralis he has
more major titles than any other player
[Applause]
the fourth time too
three total in a row
device is consistently incredible other
great players rise and fall but device
continues to spearhead the greatest team
cs has ever seen they do have a
three-man stack on this side device
who's had a really rough game flashed
he's gonna get that shot and that has to
feel a little bit good out middle of the
air to take down alex and now they're
pushing oh oh really gonna be kidding me
he takes every single one
from nothing to the awps
the number seven spot on our list is
reserved for the swedish god himself
armada the greatest melee player of all
time
[Music]
he became the best player in europe and
then the world i systematically taking
apart every opponent he faced armada
bleeds
armada something
you've never seen
oh what the [ __ ]
[Applause]
he has countless tournament wins under
his belt with two evo trophies three
genesis titles and an insane four
straight smash summit wins armada was a
god among gods and his legacy will stand
the test of time
armada has taken evil for the first time
coming in at number six is the man with
the most evo titles in history justin
wong
[Applause]
oh my god
with a career longer than some esports
players entire lives justin has
accomplished just about everything a
fighting game player can he's an eight
time evo champion and we can't even
count the number of trophies and medals
he has back home oh my god
takes it
he's done it
unbelievable he's back justin's
influence on fighting games can't be
understated the man is a living legend
he has the best fundamentals in the
business and is one of the most
legendary players not just in the fgc
but in esports history they just use the
last twist oh wait a minute here we go
oh
do not tell me do not tell me are we
going to the second set i want to see it
let's see
[Applause]
coming in at number five is no tail the
single most successful dota player of
all time from 2015 to 2017 no tail and
og won four out of valve's seven majors
but ti always seemed to escape their
grasp that all changed in 2018 when no
tail led an underdog og to victory at
ti-8 in what has gone down as the
greatest cinderella run in esports
history low lgd that song is never two
minutes
[Applause]
and then next year they did it again
[Applause]
is an innovator the founder of one of
the first player owned orgs in history
he's a master scouter always finding
talented young players just before they
break out into the mainstream he's a
great player and a champion sure but
he's so much more out of all the things
you could have decided to call yourself
why big daddy does it feel like big
daddy do you yeah in the game or in life
in life
everywhere all the time in game other
game big daddy has it changed your play
definitely how so
i'm a bigger daddy now
coming in at number four is the man
simply known as the beast
is a man with a ton of titles but his
trophies don't tell the full story he's
been playing fighting games at the
highest level for over two decades and
still goes toe to toe with the best
players in the world
back in the corner
no overhead so i can just take it
oh oh god be your wrestler no
stop meeting qc oh
he's one of the only players to hold
back-to-back evo titles the first ever
sponsored fighting game player and he
happens to be the god of 2d fighting
games not to mention the fact that he's
the man behind the legendary evo moment
37.
[Applause]
daigo was a pioneer he didn't just
dominate fighting games he created a
path for aspiring pros to follow all
around the world he's a god but more
importantly he's an inspiration he's the
final boss of fighting games everyone
wants to either beat the beast or be the
beast
taking the number three spot on our list
is quite possibly the greatest cs player
of all time
neo
but neo and bialy are still alive not
for much longer just on the opening has
four players to find and frank there's
one there's a second one and the fact
that robino is low now makes this
possible he's actually on for the ace as
well so there's so many accolades that
neo could be picking up for himself can
he get this yes he can he's gonna get
the fourth one and now it's all on
rabino who must be wondering what's
happening neo he clutches unbelievable
now if you're new to cs you might not
realize this but neo is a legend back in
1.6 he picked up an insane six major
titles and he made the top four 10 times
from 2006 all the way to 2012 neo
dominated cs
between the poles right now a couple of
aks a galil and some beagles and it's
not ideal but neo
gets into that main area oh turns and
neo with a double now
how about this for a round they have two
smokes left and that's a really big
problem for neil because he has a
molotov and i bet he would love to use
the divine time but they've already
smoked out the bomb there's another
headshot coming through he'd have to go
for the ace clutch into winning the
semi-finals here looking for another
spray neo's gonna get it he goes for
more spray for the one he's out of bonus
are you kidding me picks it up ace
clutch right into the grand finals neo
cs go career was less impressive than
his 1.6 days but he still picked up a
major title and dozens of premier
tournament victories taco he's held out
of position he'll mull the top off on
cat cause he knows one's there but it's
already found
neo gets
it and vertus bro
they'll pick it up they were determined
all week
and they prove it
our runner-up is bar none the greatest
league of legends player of all time
faker
i'm like even though i only have a man
on the floor i think he's in the bed oh
baker may be in trouble you're dead mark
tries to clean it up for ryu oh look at
the glass look at the moves faker what
was that baker with a huge play the
to people all over the world faker is
synonymous with esports he was the face
of league of legends for an entire
generation of aspiring pros and fans
because his skills transcended the game
[Music]
a three-time world champion two-time msi
champion and holds eight domestic titles
faker is dominance personified baker had
laid down orbs there's the ultimate dog
now oh and a knife
he stars in commercials teams offer him
blank checks to sign with them and his
own organization was willing to make him
a part owner to make sure he sticks
around but through it all faker has
remained dedicated to the game dedicated
to improvement and victory he's the
model esports competitor the most
legendary player of his era
but before faker there was another
taking the top spot on our list is the
ultimate weapon the last great bonjour
flash he's going back in
there and he does manage to take out
that spine crawler should be another big
hit
oh
a gigantic connection the title bonjour
is reserved for players who stand above
all others and no one has stood above
their competition quite like flash
and these links are going to make short
with these tanks but look how many tanks
he has behind there flash
flash is the single greatest starcraft
brood war player of all time and it
isn't even close in a game that
attracted the highest level of
competition a game with nearly a decade
of development before he even started
playing
flash was a god oh my god he's moving
down here it looks like he could be
going for the final blow and i'm not
sure if godzilla has enough this is it
the last part of godzilla's army is
gonna go down and flash is gonna be your
world cyber games champion he's gonna
win this without dropping a single game
against coach ladies and gentlemen
he began his career as one of the
youngest pro gamers to ever play a
televised match and picked up the
nickname little monster then he got to
work from 2007 to 2015 flash dominated
the world boasting a 70 win rate in
every matchup and he had the longest run
as the number one ranked player in korea
flash's dominance effectively brought
brood war back to life people flocked
back to that game to watch his
incredible skill and his legendary
rivalry with jaedong even after the rise
of starcraft 2 flash kept going he
became the second player to win a
premier tournament in both brood war and
starcraft 2 before he retired then he
went back to brood war and dominated it
again proving that one true god of
starcraft will forever be the greatest
of all time flash 4-0 the greatest gamer
of all time
reminds the world
who's on top flash has beaten everybody
there is no one like him and i don't
know if there ever will be again
yeah he did it
well guys that's our list i can't
believe we never did it before hell we
might not ever do it again i mean some
of these players are going to remain
legendary for years if not decades to
come
but if we ever do have to revisit this
list you're going to want to know about
it and the best way to do that obviously
is to subscribe to the channel and while
you're here go ahead and give this video
a like and let me know in the comments
below what you thought of the list
well you know that was a pretty good
list i mean i'm proud of it don't get me
wrong but i think we kind of aired a
little bit in the ranking i mean number
one should obviously have been phase
nico number two
maybe phase rain number three could have
been phase called zera not sk called
zero obviously number four oh maybe
guardian throw him a bone and hey look
we can start off the list at number 10
with faze brokey you know he's a new
player but he's pretty legendary at this
point yeah
you know what actually colton i'm going
to read you this list so yeah if you can
just re-edit it re-export get this up
next week